i started making
films i've told this story a bunch
because i wanted to see
paintings move the more you
suffer the less you want to create
van gogh did suffer but i think
he didn't suffer what i was paying
he went out to paint because he loved to
paint
find your own voice stay true to the
voice
and true to the ideas i like
uh habitual behavior because it's it's a
known factor
and then your mind is free to think
about other things
insist upon final cut
and it's sort of it's an honest film but
it's very abstract
so it's not fair for me to say that's a
definite you know way that has to be
interpreted
no no idea no idea and then
boom you see it you hear
it you feel it you know it
all at once the film is
such a beautiful language it can it can
do abstractions
the most important thing is what you
fall in love with and the reason you
fall in love
is an abstraction nobody knows why they
fall in love with this woman and not
this one
this is not like anything you've ever
done before
right i um
it was it was curious i i i'm reading
the script and i'm i'm feeling things
and i've always said that the film
is such a beautiful language it can it
can do abstractions
it can do abstractions and it
abstractions are they're the combination
of all these different elements that you
have in a film
um it can do an abstraction of emotion
and i felt this emotion coming from the
script
and that's what i really that's what lit
my fire
that the emotion of what the emotion
coming from a scene
from a word from a look
when you read something we all have the
experience we picture it in our minds
and those pictures those initial things
are what guide us from then on and so as
this thing
you know i was picturing it i'm at the
same time i'm feeling
things and i'm thinking film can do this
and it could be beautiful
this is a very beautiful important
question
and this is part of the myth i think
van gogh did suffer he suffered a lot
but i think he didn't suffer while he
was painting
he went out to paint because he loved to
paint
and it might have been one of the
happiest only happy times in his life
when he was painting
it was so thrilling for him to be
painted but he didn't need to be
suffering
to do those great paintings and i know
van gogh would have been happier if he'd
been able to transcend dive with him
and i know his work would have been as
good better or
even better than good it stands to
reason
the more you suffer the less you
want to create the if you're truly
depressed
they say you can't even get out of bed
let alone create
if you're truly angry occupies the whole
brain
poisons the artist poisons the
environment
little room for creativity and i use
this example
if you have a splitting headed splitting
headache
and you have nausea your vomiting
and you have diarrhea on top of that
how much work are you going to be doing
and how much are you going to enjoy it
give the person the technique to lift
that sickness
lift that negativity and enjoy life
but i guarantee you if you have enough
stress you won't be able to create
and if you have enough conflict it will
just get in the way of your creativity
you
you you can understand conflict but you
don't have to suffer in it
and you can get ideas from it the whole
world most things we just reflect the
world they just reflect the world
and but i say if you're really and truly
depressed
you can't get even get out of bed you
can't create
and if but if you've got a notion of um
because you want to live the art life
and you've got this melancholy you know
thing and the chicks really
dig this then you'll just keep playing
that role
but you're not really suffering some
people have heard the story that i went
to
bob's big boy for seven years every day
at 2 30 and had the same thing that was
my longest
habit pattern i think but
i like habitual behavior because
it's it's a known factor and then your
mind is free to think about other things
good morning good morning it's september
16 november 12 2020
and it's a monday and it's a wednesday
thursday
here in l.a here in a clear morning
about 45 degrees fahrenheit
here we go for today's number it's
september
30 november 2
10 balls numbers one through ten
swirl the numbers swirl the numbers
pick a number today's number is
nine four nine today's
number wes is seven
so what are you eating at first tell me
what you're eating i'm eating um
for lunch tomatoes tuna fish feta cheese
and uh olive oil now here's what's
interesting about you
you eat that every day every day every
day you eat the same thing
yeah it's well i it's it's very good you
know i'm sure it is
otherwise we wouldn't eat it every day
right right so what do we eat for dinner
chicken little pieces of chicken and
broccoli and a little soy sauce
every day yeah every day except when i
travel then i go off that
is this can we can we say you're a
creature of habit
yes uh habit in a daily routine
and um and then when there's some sort
of
order there then you're free to mentally
go off
uh any any place you've got a safe sort
of
foundation and and a place to spring off
from yeah
and and you view that in terms of the
creative process it's very important
it's very important for me for you right
you don't like a cluttered room when
you're thinking
no i the the pure the environment
the more you know fantastic the interior
world can be it seems to me do you have
any advice for maybe
younger artists sure how to do that it's
very simple to do that
um and succeed well now that's not a
guarantee
see that's the problem um
there's a bunch of stuff you could say
but i always say
for anybody find your own voice
uh stay true to the voice and true to
the ideas
never turn down a good idea but never
take a bad idea
always have final cut
insist upon final cut
if whoever these people are that are
giving you the right to make this or
funding it they have to trust
the filmmaker to
you know make the film the way he or she
wants it made
and if you don't have final cut what
you're saying is
this isn't my film these are this is i
will never
be guaranteed that i can hold my head up
high and say this is my work
because somebody's going to come in and
fiddle with it i always say the painter
is painting a picture people don't come
in and say i don't like that particular
blue
change that blue or i don't like this i
would you
the artist would probably leap on the
person and
and beat him you know and and uh so
the same way with all the arts you have
to have freedom
and you need support from the people you
work with
and you should have fun in the doing you
should go down the room
a road with like a family uh working
together
and enjoying the work i write them down
so i don't commit suicide
later having forgotten the idea yeah
i've forgotten probably two or three
major ideas and it may make you sick
it just horrible write the idea down you
say well i'll never
forget this idea you can
do feel this thing in the air and it
might
alter our thinking a hair um
you you you don't know what you're going
to fall in the most important thing is
what you fall in love with
and the reason you fall in love is an
abstraction nobody knows why they fall
in love with this woman and not this one
yeah or why they fall out of love or why
they fall out well they know that a lot
of times
yes they do but
so and you can't figure it out in other
words you can't you can't sit here and
say to me i can tell you what was in the
air it was this this and there's no no
it's just it's a it's a beautiful
beautiful extraction of some kind of a
psychic thing
i know that there's a thing called
writer's block
but just that
term uh if it becomes kind of a reality
if you believe in that term
you could maybe uh get writer's block
and um uh fearing it you would bring it
to yourself
or i don't know if that's true but um
all it means is the ideas are not coming
uh you out fishing your hook is in the
water you've got bait on it
but you're not catching anything today
so
it doesn't it doesn't it just means that
uh you just keep fishing you have to
have patience
i started making films
i've told this story a bunch because i
wanted to see
paintings move
what happened to me though when i
started
making films with stop motion
love for this medium
of film started growing
a love for it and ideas started coming
ideas for cinema
and i always say that every medium that
we have available
is infinitely deep and these mediums
will
talk to us and once we start
getting a dialogue with the mediums
ideas flow for them
and it's magical you
um you're going along
there's no idea no
no idea no idea and then
boom it's like like you could say
a big movie screen in your head in your
brain
this idea comes on the screen
and you see it
you hear it you feel it you know it
all at once and then
you go and write it down
and you write it down i say with words
so that when you read that those words
again later that idea will come back in
full
david lynch has described his uh film
eraserhead in this manner
a dream of dark and troubling things
and uh would you like to expound on that
a little no
no what sort of reaction
were you thinking of do you want people
to have or do you want
anyone well see the thing is like when
we were making the film
we weren't thinking about an audience i
wasn't thinking
i was i mean i wasn't really thinking
about
what it would be do we would sometimes
fantasize you know and think you know
but we never really thought that we'd
even get it just
distributed you know and uh
i remember when filmix came around we
thought this was it it's going to be
seen
one time and that's going to be it and
um so
the reaction it the eraserhead is
eraserhead you know and it was
it was meant to be just that way and
however people
react to it is is you know is fine
and the next film i make i'd rather i'd
like to think more about
an audience and you know what they're
going to be reacting to and like that
but
uh it wasn't that i i just went about it
haphazardly
eraserhead was a real definite you know
thing in my head but um i didn't think
about how people were going to react to
it
anything goes you know like if somebody
sees it
and wants to make a political film out
of it you know they can do that you know
it's it's fine with me because it's not
fair for me to say oh you didn't get it
you know because the film is
is so abstract and but it's not
just like throwing together abstract
it's
it's meant to be abstract it's meant to
be that way abstract you know so it has
a
it has a right kind of feeling to me and
it's sort of
it's an honest film but it's very
abstract
so it's not fair for me to say that it's
a definite you know way that has to be
interpreted
you